what is going on everybody
welcome to another monte carlo tutorial
video with python
uh where we left off we were generating
some data
and we were just saving it to a
csv and basically the data in that csv
is if the data is better than
uh one percent or worse than negative
one percent
then we want to know what variables
contributed to that data
and then we save that to the csv so
now what we want to do is we want to
chart it up and visualize the data
because what we're looking for is if
there's any clumps of data either in
positive or negative
that can kind of give us a bit of an
idea
of variables
that correspond to either
the positive or negative changes
so with that what we're going to do is
i'm going to get rid of this i'm just
going to literally delete everything in
here i suggest you save yours just in
case you want to revisit the code later
on or you want to run your own tests
so take a moment and save the data maybe
just
go file new and open yourself up a blank
script anyway i'm going to clear my now
now
and start anew so what we're doing here
is we're going to start plotting this
stuff so
of course if you want to plot you need
matplot lib
and then we want to import matte
matte plot lib.pi plot
as plt i assume everybody at this point
has matplotlib since we needed it
earlier in the video so anyway and then
we also want to import csv
because we saved this data to a csv now
we want to graph this stuff so
we're going to have a define graph
empty parameter function and now we're
going to say with
open uh
file name here we have money carlo
liberal.csv with the intention to read
and we're going to open this as monte
carlo
data is going to equal csv dot
reader and what do we want to read well
we want to read monte carlo
with a delimiter delimiter
of a comma because that was our
delimiter so
again we're using csv.reader which is we
imported csv up here
and basically this is just python's
csv reading app or module basically so
just a good way to easily read the
contents of a csv
file so
when you use it you just have to tell it
what is it reading and then what's the
delimiter and it automatically
understands new line and all that so
we've got data's next what we want to do
is for
each line in datas we want to do
something with this data just so happens
we want to plot it
um so we're going to need to explain
what's what here
so first we're going to say percent
roi that is equal to the float
of each line zero
uh wager size percent
equals flow each
line one and what we've got going on
here
is it's automatically being divided up
by
the comma delimiter so each line and
datas
is spit out as a list and you've got
chunks in that list and it's
just so happens it's split up in the uh
in the way that we set it up so anyway
moving on
um so the next part in that list is
wager
count and that is equal to the flow of
each
line two and then finally
p color for plot color equals
each line three just as a quick aside in
typical debugging and all this stuff for
um python and charting and matplotlib
obviously the word
color where it doesn't really correspond
like before in this tutorial i wanted to
use results oh
and anyway or like return that was what
i wanted to use
um and that you can't do that because
return is a
you know built-in function same thing
with color though color is a built-in
parameter for you guessed it color
of plots so you can't just use color you
have to use
something else like p color just keep
that in mind when you name variables
sometimes you might name a variable that
runs over the name of a very important
variable so each time we find this data
what do we want to do with it
well we're going to scatter plot it so
plot dot scatter
and for now we'll just do a simple 2d
scatter plot
so wager size percent that's what we
care about and
wager count finally color equals p color
so we add those to the plots and then
when everything's all said and done
after the width uh we're going to plot
show
now we'll just have it automatically
call graph save it
run it and the file was actually i'm
trying to think how big my file was but
it was actually a pretty large file
so anyways we have our plot
now at least with my eyeballs um
i don't see any correlation uh
at all here this looks like a pretty
random plotting
um i mean there's some places where
you've got groups but i mean you really
have to grasp it at straws here
if you think you're seeing any sort of
pattern so i don't see any pattern
but there is an unsaid variable so far
here
and that is how much money
um so we know that this is more than one
percent
uh return on investment but we know
nothing else we just know it's more than
one percent
um so we definitely want to dig further
into this and the way we would dig
further is by how much money did we make
um you know what is that percent uh so
that's the next thing that we want to
look at so luckily
we obviously have percent roi that's one
of our variables so we can plot that
but we also kind of want to plot it
alongside this stuff so what we're going
to do
now is we're going to plot with
matplotlib's
3d capabilities so that's what we're
going to do in the next
video so stay tuned for that also
the 3d plotting is very intense for
python
so what i figured i would do is because
this is random
um it's also pretty hard to see anything
of significance
just right now anyways and i bet in the
3d we won't see too much
so i went ahead and i've been building a
file that
is that requires five percent so it has
to be a return on investment greater
than five percent or less than negative
five percent
so i've been building that at the moment
and so in my video
i've got a couple of different things
i'll show you the one percent file and
i'll also show you the five percent and
all of that so
anyway that's what we're going to be
doing the next video is plotting this on
a 3d plot so we can actually see
all of the variables here so that should
be pretty interesting
uh as always thanks for watching thanks
for all the support and subscriptions
and until next time